[Laughter]
i just had a little spit up
a little spit up
yeah it's getting hot now
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by dave grohl he's a
16-time grammy award-winning artist
whose story career and music has been
immortalized in the rock and roll hall
of fame on two separate occasions he has
a recently released new york times
bestselling book as well the storyteller
tales of life and music and get this a
comedy horror movie starring the foo
fighters is on the way studio 666 which
is set to release on february 25th dave
grohl welcome to the show hi
i'm stoked man i've been waiting to do
this for years you know i would say in
the years since gordon ramsay you're
probably the most requested guest that
we've ever had on the show five years in
the making finally it's for the fans
dave are you ready to rock i am ready to
rock i feel like gordon had a hard time
well the british palette is that what it
is yeah maybe i should have a drinking
game with him sometime oh drinking game
you say yeah i mean i like i thought you
know to return the favor since you're
hosting me and having me on your show
that
i would bring a couple cocktails and
maybe every few wings we could have a
little drink let's go let's do this
thing yeah
[Music]
let's just do one little shot let's do
it okay let's do it
now i don't know if you know about
pantera
but they're the most wicked heavy metal
band of all time and they would do these
shots they call them black tooth grins
and you can make it a few different ways
but it's basically like a little bit of
crown a little bit of coke this is
getting messy in a sweet little [ __ ]
cocktail like this they go back smooth
cheers cheers to pantera it's a pantera
so we're gonna hit one of these real
quick
hell yeah
they work too there we go you gotta
[ __ ] be careful with that [ __ ]
[Music]
i've had this sauce before
no it's good no it goes
that's something i think i would have in
my house
oh well you know what
that you can take along with you
you're not the only one i can bring this
at home everything you're not the only
one bringing gifts today dave
constellation prize
exactly
so your new film studio 666 draws
inspiration from the foo fighters tenth
studio album which likewise was recorded
in a possibly haunted encino mansion
steeped in rock history what were your
original expectations for the project i
read a quote of yours recently where you
enthusiastically and maybe even
surprisingly declared it's a movie movie
well
about three years ago i was writing
music for medicine at midnight and when
i do that i like to demo stuff by myself
where i'll set up a little studio
write instrumentals and i'll play the
you know write these things and send
them to the guys and say hey what do you
think does this sound like a good song
but i like to do it in private and so i
was looking for a house where i could
just like
shut everything off and just record
and then i'm in this creepy old house
demoing stuff i'm like why don't we just
make the record here take a little bit
of time off and then make a super quick
low budge slasher run and gun horror
film and so i came up with this idea
like oh i know the foo fighters move
into a house it's [ __ ] haunted
i become possessed i [ __ ] kill
everybody and then i go solo and that
was it that was the pitch and everyone's
like okay and then also there's millions
of dollars thrown around like way
like
and [ __ ] special effects and [ __ ]
like that
when we started seeing the dailies or
the cuts coming back we're like oh my
god this is a [ __ ] movie
something we never expected we would do
but i feel like we're the band to do
something that [ __ ] stupid because
that's all we've done for 26 years you
know you watch our videos and [ __ ]
[Music]
caesar smoke garlic i like everything
smoked i got almonds
that would go i would i would hit some
brisket with that you know what
that's such an amazing segue here to the
next question because your deep and
abiding love of barbecue you have a
quote that i think would make any food
writer jealous where you say
you create a recipe as you would a song
you prepare a meal as you would a record
when people come back for seconds well
that's your encore what's the key to a
good rub in your opinion
simplicity so i just like a real good
mixture of just salt and pepper because
that'll really always bring out whether
it's pork or beef
you can get fancy with sugars
you can get fancy with cumin and things
like that
but i'm really simple when it comes to
that stuff because
it really comes down to the time and the
temperature in the smoke and if you let
all of those things like sit and rest
at the right place for the right amount
of time
you want the taste of the meat you know
more so than the taste of a rub that's
just me i mean i love sweet barbecue too
um
but man i love it when it's just like a
real good piece of meat that's smoked
perfectly right
they're the two types of barbecue chefs
there's like the ones that are like
really get into the molecular breakdown
and the [ __ ] science of barbecue and
then there's the other guys that just
take a pig and throw it on fire and
[ __ ] wait around and like they're
both amazing but i love like someone
like sam jones barbecue goes back in his
family like [ __ ] hundred years or
something like that and i really respect
that because then it becomes tradition
it's like heritage maybe there's a
connection to between the the barbecue
pit masters and the drummers you know
the the people who are technical and who
are on the on the pace and on the timing
and then the people who just bang the
[ __ ] off yeah well that's every
drummer's best excuse
like i'm a field drummer like i don't
know how to and that's just because they
don't [ __ ] know how to do the fancy
[ __ ] like that's me like nah man i'm
like a disco drummer because i'm not
[ __ ] good enough to play rush that's
basically what it is
[Music]
italy vibe oh really the calabrian
chilies yeah
we do have one hot sauce guru in our
crew a dude named sean whoa yeah
it's true imagine that i told him to
yesterday i was coming on the show
he's trying to give me tips and [ __ ]
he's like
make sure you have some milk before you
go
it's not about the mouth it's about your
[ __ ] or whatever
it's good advice no
we've had countless number of top five
mc lists on the show and don't worry i
won't ask you to do one for drummers but
i am curious what you think people get
wrong when they debate the greatest
drummers of all time
my sign of a good drummer
would be if you hear
about 15 seconds of their playing and
you know who it is no matter how
technical you just know who it is the
distinct sound the feel and feel is
indefinable it's like a fingerprint you
know i wrote a whole [ __ ] essay about
feel because
some people
i
think
believe that it can be created but it's
not i mean it's just as
signature as your soul or your voice or
your heart or whatever
so if you were to have a sheet of music
and have two different drummers play
that same sheet of music it would sound
different because of their
lives and their heart and soul and
whatever so
if you hear 15 seconds of ringo starr
you [ __ ] know it's ringo starr if you
hear 15 seconds of john bonham you know
it's john bonham are they two entirely
different players absolutely is one more
technical than the other absolutely but
does that amount to what is that like
what does that amount to
you know if your name is attached to a
very specific thing then you [ __ ] got
it
let's do a shot let's do a shot let's do
a shot
[Laughter]
i mean that's to me that's the thing
like and i think it makes sense like
unless you go
i'm trying to keep the ice out of it so
you don't [ __ ] choke on that [ __ ]
here put a little coke in there very
considerate
yeah and i mean you know and drummers
dude when you get [ __ ] drummers
talking about drums
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] get stuck
cheers cheers dave all right
[Music]
that was a big ass shot
angry phoenix sounds like a [ __ ]
tenacious d song
oh it's got scotch bonnets in it
you know
i spent a lot of time on youtube
you do
because i have the attention span of a
nat
and uh
i do enjoy watching
people [ __ ] themselves up with hot
sauce
you've seen the hot one show before
maybe
a couple times
i mean i could [ __ ] rail off all of
my favorite episodes i got i got some
faves i gotta be honest i love watching
it
i thought billy eilish did great amazing
she did a good job doing laps running
laps around this gordon ramsay
just pissed the whole [ __ ] time over
170 f-bombs i think that first episode
[Laughter]
the d
classic classic
you know actually
i'm a huge fan of thundercat i love
thundercat i mean his music's [ __ ]
amazing he's a genius like i really
think he's a genius
and uh i met him for the first time
about a month ago at a party oh awesome
he was on a dance floor
dancing like this and so i went up
behind him and just started coming up
around him like this
and his girlfriend's looking at me she's
like she's laughing but he has no idea
who it is
and then finally i spun him around i'm
writing his face he's like
and i didn't say anything about his
music i was like dude you're the best
[ __ ] hot ones episode i've ever seen
oh
you know what next time i see him i
can't wait to get that story out of him
he's the [ __ ] king oh that's awesome
amazing i love that
this is everything i dreamed it to be
you having a good time yeah i can taste
blood this is great
[Music]
so i'm gonna burp a lot i just burp
i'm zapping i do i burp on stage too and
sometimes my [ __ ] burps get more
applause than our songs
fyi
this is a good sounding burp
i like this
yeah you know why i like this please
tell me
it kind of tastes like b.o
[Laughter]
is that that earthy summer
[ __ ] bus yeah i'm trying to get home
you're like
it's good earthy let's say earthy earthy
yeah it's like someone that does use
deodorant they use [ __ ] crystals and
[ __ ] yeah yeah or maybe this now we'll
we'll make a spray
all right dave we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull the picture up over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story okay
all right first things first
in 2015 you famously finished a show in
sweden after falling off the stage two
songs in and severely breaking your leg
what's the second most severe injury
that you've ever suffered while
performing
while performing we were getting hit in
the face with a half dollar in atlanta
in like 1996 and i'm like god [ __ ]
damn it and went to the hospital they're
like okay we'll get with you in a couple
minutes i sat there for five [ __ ]
hours and then they finally got to me
they're like
yeah it's too late just put a band-aid
on it god damn it um oh i got
electrocuted once on stage like
we played some [ __ ] corporate gig for
like doc martens in las vegas
and it was
like some hotel and there was a pool and
the stage was right by this pool
and i thought it would be funny
if i
invite the whole audience into the pool
with me at during this like jam i'm like
come on everybody and i [ __ ] jump in
the pool
and the whole audience follows me to the
pool
and we're all kind of partying and then
i go back on stage someone hands me the
guitar and i step on my my distortion
pedal i was like
it was like actual electrocution
that sucked
how would you distill your connection to
the late show with david letterman
between being his final music act and
then paying homage to him when he guest
hosted kimmel does seem like a unique
bond there one of the reasons i love
letterman is because his show is so
musical you know he always had really
cutting-edge music acts on the show
and i mean to be honest like
he just seemed like a wicked smart ass
and those are the people i [ __ ] hang
out with you know i want i want my best
friend to be smarter and funnier
and more [ __ ] ride than anyone and so
i honestly felt i spent my whole life
watching him
so i really felt like you know he was my
[ __ ] friend in a way
he had this connection to our music i
guess he liked our song ever long
after his heart surgery we came back and
we played a show
and he's a dave dude
dave's gotta [ __ ] stick together
hold on let's do a [ __ ] shot let's do
a [ __ ] shot oh dude we have a song
called sean you do we do we recorded a
song called sean i didn't know that in
austin texas at the saint cecilia hotel
it's called shawn the saint cecilia
hotel is pretty cool it's [ __ ] and we
recorded it in the bar at saint cecilia
hotel we made a whole record there what
it's called the saint cecilia lp
ep and it's we got a song called shawn
oh [ __ ] you know what the chorus says
what shot
[Laughter]
sounds like a hit to sean cheers dave
it was not a hit by the way
[Music]
so it's interesting
sure
let's go on real
quick [ __ ] double up
what were you talking about
[Laughter]
cheers dave sean i'm gonna send you that
[ __ ] song i can't wait
so it's interesting to me that when you
began your career starter meant
teenagers putting your poster on the
wall and being the definition of
untouchable but now we live in an era of
such widespread accessibility and so
many different ways to reach an audience
what excites you most when you see young
artists building a wave in the internet
age and then what if anything worries
you about the new ways that music is
discovered and consumed
i still believe
that the most important way
to promote yourself as an artist is to
[ __ ] play live
that's it because when someone sees when
a human being sees another human being
on stage
ripping
it there's there is this sort of
connection and it's inspiring because
you're like oh my god human beings can
do that you know i think we've been so
conditioned to everything becoming kind
of mechanical in a way that you see it
and you're like oh yeah that's cool like
yeah look at the lights and look at the
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if you see someone
sitting in front of you
with just wooden wires shredding a
guitar or someone with an amazing voice
and no microphone or like the
preservation hall jazz band in new
orleans you go sit in that tiny room and
there's no microphones there's no
nothing it's just church pews and a jazz
band and it moves your heart
that's the way to do it i'm convinced
so i remember years ago
looking at like a festival's schedule
and seeing this being alabama shakes and
they're like halfway up the bill on the
side stage
coming back to the festival like a year
or two later and seeing alabama shakes
headlining the side stage i'm like oh
damn
and then a couple years later coming
back and they're [ __ ] halfway up the
main stage and i'm like oh [ __ ] coming
back a couple years later and now
they're headlining the main stage
then going to the [ __ ] grammys and
we're in the same category as them and
they [ __ ] take the grammy that's how
you're supposed to do it that's what i
think you gotta get out there beat the
[ __ ] street and play live and be a
badass if you're a [ __ ] badass that
[ __ ] will happen
but you gotta work it
i'm gonna [ __ ] throw up how about
that
it's a little sweet and sticky mm-hmm
and then
[Music]
that profound pepper hits but look at
you dave crawl
i mean it's hot
it's good no that's a good hot sauce and
you're right that is a good barbecue
it's got a little sweet in it yep
it's got a little sticky on it
you could put it on some [ __ ]
so i read that foo fighters recorded an
album to tape so that nobody could mess
with it afterwards in your opinion does
over producing or over manipulating a
song undermine what it means to make
music in any way for the foo fighters
yes for other people i don't know
i like imperfection
um i like to
hear albums where you can hear
a hand going up and down the strings and
there's like finger slidings and then
like little the tempo goes like this and
that's the you know it's the human
element of music i dig that um
[Music]
oh
i don't have hair but i felt like i got
like it was like that mask while tapes
commercial back in the day what was i
saying
probably will i
pontificate about the human element of
music uh no i mean you know what there
are some things about music like
really rigid mechanical music that i
[ __ ] love i really do
i think we're kind of best when it
sounds like us and it's raw
i've heard about the bomb
cups are empty
get some [ __ ]
come on sean
let's go baby let's go do this
all right dave cheers cheers
to the bible what's the most painful
thing that's ever happened to you
oh other than being dumped at the prom
what's the most painful that was you at
homecoming on the [ __ ]
i read the book dave i read the [ __ ]
book i read the book
cheers cheers here's the heartbreak
[Music]
it was crazy that this is your [ __ ]
job
well your job's [ __ ] crazy too
yeah i got something
i'm just trying to be as badass as lord
and [ __ ] thunder well you're lord
esque
yeah but she had all these like culinary
notes like yeah
man i'm like hiccuping over here
that is where you turn the corner though
yeah it gets hot right different yeah it
does a different vibe altogether yeah
and you don't want one of my beers get
some beer
i got some oh you do
buddy you can do this brother oh i got
you
yeah dave i'm on the ride with you right
now
i just had a little spit up
a little spit up
yeah it's getting hot now yeah it is
yeah it is
so between the sound city tour and then
being a part-time member of the taylor
hawkins chevy metal cover band you have
a lot of experience exploring the work
of other legendary musicians yeah what
do you learn by playing other people's
music live
so taylor's band chevy metal
has this awesome list of cover songs
one of them being
um
turning japanese
turning japanese yeah i think i'm
turning into japanese i really think so
and you listen to it on the radio and
you're like 10.
and then you play it on guitar like oh
my god this is so [ __ ] hard
i remember once trying to play message
in a bottle and i [ __ ] pulled a
muscle in my hand playing a police song
i was like
how do the police do this without
hurting themselves
like some people
some musicians you sit there and you
talk and you're like yeah yeah what's up
but then you put on instruments and you
start playing and you actually get to
know the person better
without words
with instruments
because everyone does it differently
it's pretty red
you're by the way
lord ask
come on now i'm not just saying that
come on dom is coming in because she
sees
like tears coming out of my eyes no i'm
good and yeah dave you are good
you are good
really yeah this is
um come on dude in the shop all right
let's do the damn thing
what's that [ __ ] whiskey
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean yes it's hot
okay it's hot
i'm gonna chill it for you yeah since
you're burning up so hot
thank you dave
[Music]
bernard okay
that's gonna help
yeah you're right or not
well you know what we're just on this
ride
you're gonna make it dude
promise
well that
that gave me all the confidence i need
cheers [ __ ] kidding
[Music]
mommy will you pass the pucker
this is [ __ ] what
it's hot
yeah
but nothing dave grohl can't handle
choking out the whole damn lineup
choking out the whole damn lineup
so you've been a self-described ufo nerd
for decades and i'm curious how that
interest peaked i've heard you reference
the 1987
best-selling book above top secret by
timothy good
when i was a kid i had a lot of ufo
dreams
and like really i'm as crazy vivid
dreamers still to this day
like i remember
the music in my dream from last night
like every [ __ ] day i wake up i
remember my dreams
and um
when i was a kid i would have these
awesome ufo dreams where like
i'd be lying in my front yard in
springfield virginia
and i'd be staring up at the stars
and i'm like wow and then i realized
like oh my god it's not the stars it's
the underside of this mirror [ __ ]
glass-shaped ship thing and that was
taking me to space so i always thought
that ufos were kind of real
and um i convinced all my friends in my
neighborhood that i was ufo expert
and they'd be like
come over to my yard i think i saw a ufo
last night and i'd walk over their yard
and be like
yeah see that like discolored grass
right there that might be a crop circle
or whatever so from an early age i was
super into ufos
i read this book above top secret and in
that i saw the term foo fighters and
here we are you want to hit the [ __ ]
right now yeah of course
let's go we're rocking
sure yeah
did you see his face in the back i got
real
yeah
i demand another shot i insist on
another shot
if you say so
[Laughter]
all right last shot last shot [ __ ] that
[ __ ] last ring
last wing
drink that
all right cheers dave god damn it sean
[Music]
i mean i gotta be honest i'm not kidding
dude
when i was a kid
i learned to love music
watching saturday night live
and i walked on to that set for the
first time in 1992. like holy [ __ ] i'm
here as a teenager i [ __ ] watched
the david letterman show
every [ __ ] night as i did bong hit
after bong hit after bonk
some parallels walked onto that
[ __ ] stage i'm like oh my god i'm
here
for years i've watched this [ __ ] show
and i finally walked onto this set and
saw those sauces and saw your face i was
like
yes
bucket list bam
the only thing i have left to do in my
life is jammed with ac dc
dave i can't handle that
i don't know how to process that
i'm just saying
that
are we hitting the last dab what are we
doing let's [ __ ] hit this last dab
let's hit a [ __ ] last shot
let's put the dab on let's put the dab
on i got the dab on
hold on a second let's talk about love
all right i was kidding
one more shot one more shot yeah one
more shot and one more wing let's do a
shot we'll chase it with the wing
ooh wing chaser wing chaser or shot
chaser depending on how you want to line
it up
oh you know what i gotta do [ __ ] it
tomorrow i gotta go to narnia
what i gotta go to narnia what's in
nadia nadia business
come on now
well you know what i almost think it
would be like
silly to ask a wing 10 question let's
eat this wing let's eat this wing dave
okay
and what a ride it's been
yeah man
did you put a dab on it oh yeah you hit
it right i heard that [ __ ] i hit that
[ __ ]
[Music]
i've got a confession in my
i got a confession
like that
just you know
i have this [ __ ] at home
sometimes i come home from rehearsal
[Music]
did that sound like elvis
sometimes i come home
from rehearsal
i drink a couple beers
and eat a teaspoon of this [ __ ]
so you know what
hot ones
i got your ass
taking on the wings of death
choking out the gauntlet living to tell
the tale and still making his rehearsal
tonight at 6 p.m and now dave gold
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
got a horror movie coming out how about
that [ __ ] and then i'm in the band
called the foo fighters we're gonna play
a bunch of shows and then [ __ ] you
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't tell you what this means
don't get emotional get the box no i i
might don't that guy at the bar no i do
i care i care i care
let's hug
no i care that [ __ ] much and
you're the [ __ ] man
that's so [ __ ] good dude
you're drunk
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience in one convenient package i'm
proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]